we're getting rare insight from police
officers about the challenges of
fighting racism inside a department a
growing number of police departments in
America's largest cities told us they've
added implicit bias training but
hundreds of officers in multiple states
have recently been exposed for racist
social media posts attacking minorities
and promoting racial stereotypes Jeff
McGee spoke to one st. Louis Police
Sergeant whose department has officers
at the center of that controversy he
continues our investigation into
policing in America five years after
Ferguson Jeff what did that officer tell
you the st. Louis metro police officer
that you're about to hear from says the
culture among her department's top brass
is allowing bad cops to slip through the
cracks when we asked if the department
had training to address possible racial
bias the answer wasn't clear do you
think that there are white supremacists
on the police force yes you didn't even
pause have you seen some of the Facebook
posts of some of our suspended officers
right now yes
Heather Taylor is an almost 19 year
veteran on the st. Louis metro police
force she points to the recent report by
the Plainview project which flagged
thousands of racist and derogatory
social media posts including some from
22 current st. Louis metro officers like
this one that compared black lives
matter to the KKK as president of the
ethical society of police a
predominantly black local union taylors
mission is to root out racial
discrimination among police protests in
Ferguson took place about ten miles from
st. Louis Metro PD headquarters and led
to changes in training there s LMPD told
CBS News and a survey that implicit bias
training has been mandatory for officers
once a year since October of 2014 that's
two months after Michael Brown's death
implicit bias training they've had that
here yes as it worked I think that's
pretty obvious that it hasn't if
implicit bias training is mandatory it
doesn't seem to have left an impression
on Heather Taylor have you been through
it no
no it was optional lieutenant Cheryl
orange a patrol officer for the
department says she doesn't remember
taking it either
wasn't it mandatory not that I recall
but it may have been we've been trying
to get s lmpd's police chief to comment
on our CBS News investigations that
found a majority of departments
nationwide are adding training to
address possible racial bias over a
period of months there have been phone
calls emails and each and every time the
Police Department has declined our
request for interviews there's a change
mm-hmm so we went to the man who hired
the police chief Jimmy Edwards is the
Public Safety Director for the city of
st. Louis we had an officer tell us she
knows that there are white supremacist
on the police force I'm not surprised my
job is to root that person out implicit
bias training isn't mandatory for all
officers yes it is it is mandatory we've
talked to officers who don't remember
taking implicit bias classes yeah well
everybody in the city of st. Louis have
taken implicit bias training and they
can't remember it I don't know that's
that's a good question for them that's
odd
it is odd still Edwards says use of
force incidents are down in st. Louis
City which he credits to new training
but he also concedes police have a long
way to go before he can assure a black
mother he met that changes have taken
hold in the department she asked me can
you change our Police Department because
every time my little black boy
encounters at police I think one or two
things is going to happen that my child
will lose its Liberty and go to prison
or that my child will die we have
challenges but we're overcoming those
challenges a bit at a time Taylor says
that should include better screening of
applicants and breaking down what some
have called the blue wall of silence a
term for police cover-ups of internal
wrongdoing your fellow officers they
might see your comments and be offended
how do you go back to work after making
comments like that because when you know
you're doing right you can hold your
head up I don't think that all of our
department is banned but instead of
complaining about
me how about you do something to change
the culture that you know exists it is
still unknown whether any police
training technique could impact transit
use of force one reason is because there
has never been a federal use of force
database to study but for the first time
the FBI is now creating one and we're
gonna have an exclusive report on that
tomorrow including an interview with the
man leading that effort Wow some amazing
stuff yeah so difficult it sounds like
to really make people change how they
really feel and I think that's the issue
you can mandate things all day long but
it's a cultural shift that has to happen
yes that's true police departments and
in society overall frankly but we were
surprised by how candid the officers
that we spoke to were with us even when
the cameras were rolling yeah part of
the problem is actually just knowing
that it still exists then maybe that's
at least the first step you have to
realize you may have a problem with your
bias training if people can't remember
taking that course well and that's what
also surprised us the fact that you know
that there was this big push to get
implicit bias training but the question
is is it working is it making a
difference maybe counseling would help
Jeff thank you very much and to see how
police departments in your state
responded to questions about training
including that racial bias training and
de-escalation training go to CBS this
morning calm we have a state-by-state
breakdown of the 155 police departments
we surveyed you can watch more of Jeff's
exclusive report tonight on the CBS
Evening News and tomorrow on CBS this
morning Jeff brings us an exclusive look
at the FBI's new effort to track use of
force across the nation for the first
time Plus Jeff discusses what went into
ctms year-long investigation on today's
CBS this morning podcast it's available
wherever you like to get your podcasts